las elecciones en perú avanzan sin
contratiempos aunque se han registrado
la demora en la instalación algunas
mesas de sufragio así como poca
concurrencia de electores en las
primeras horas de la mañana precisamente
el presidente de francisco sagasti ha
declarado que las elecciones serán con
total transparencia y ha garantizado los
resultados y al mismo tiempo ha pedido a
los candidatos keiko fujimori pedro
castillo a respetar los resultados de
las urnas resultados que diversos
analistas han previsto que va a ser con
un final de fotografía porque va a tener
resultados de márgenes muy estrecho y
justamente perú salió a votar en medio
del peor momento de la pandemia de
coronavirus arrastrando más de 186 mil
decesos por el cob y 19 precisamente por
esto las autoridades del país han
previsto el empleo de protocolos de
bioseguridad en estos comicios se ha
pedido que los electores usen doble
mascarilla y en las filas ellos guarden
un distanciamiento social así como
emplean un bolígrafo de color
para evitar los contagios